One such method of self-mummification was
practiced by Japanese Shugendō monks as the
ultimate act of self denial.
Shugendō is a form of Buddhism that originally
combined elements of Buddhism, animism, Old
Shinto, mountain worship, and Taoism, among
other religions.
“Shugendō” itself means something to
the effect of “the way to spiritual power
through discipline”.
The culmination of some of the Shugendō monk’s
lives was to voluntarily choose to mummify
themselves, a process called Sokushunbutsu.
This ritual lasted around nine years, six
of which the monk would be alive for.
The payoff for monks that achieved self-mummification
was that they were seen as a Buddha and were
then supposed to be placed in a temple for
others to see and honor.
Failed attempts, which seems to have been
the case a large percentage of the time, resulted
in the bodies simply decomposing.
As you might imagine, mummifying one’s self
is a process that is excruciatingly painful,
hence why individuals who were successful
were considered to have achieved a state of
perfect enlightenment.
The monks would begin by ceasing eating any
food except various nuts and seeds, with some
accounts stating that they were also allowed
to eat fruits and berries.
They would also begin a regimented program
of heavy physical exercise, which they would
continue throughout this first period that
lasted one thousand days.
During the next one thousand days, the monks
would further restrict their diet by only
eating bark and various roots, again with
some accounts stating that they were also
allowed to eat a limited amount of fruits
and berries.
Near the end of this period, they would drink
regular draughts of a drink made from the
sap of the Urushi tree.
This tree’s sap is mildly poisonous and
is normally used as a natural lacquer.
Ingesting the drink caused the person consuming
it to vomit frequently, further restricting
the body’s ability to obtain nutrients from
the sparse diet they ate.
They would also rapidly lose bodily fluids
due to vomiting.
This sap also has the mummifying side-effect
of acting as a preservative.
In the final stage of self-mummification,
the monk’s body would be little more than
skin and bones.
If the monk survived to this point, he would
lock himself into a stone tomb that was just
large enough for him to fit in, sitting in
the lotus position, which is a position he
would not move from until he died.
The tomb itself contained an air tube, so
that the monk could live for a time after
being entombed.
It also contained a bell, which the monk would
ring on a daily basis to let those outside
the tomb know he was still alive.
While in the tomb, the monk would sit in the
lotus position and meditate until death.
Once the monk died and, thus, no longer rang
the bell each day, the breathing tube would
be removed and the tomb sealed for the final
thousand day period of the ritual.
At the end of this period, the tomb would
be opened to see if the monk was successful
in mummifying himself.
If he was, the preserved body would be put
on display in the temple.
Having successfully demonstrated mastery over
the physical, the priest would also then be
declared a Buddha.
This practice continued until around the 19th
century when it was outlawed by the Japanese
government.
While the bodies of these monks were supposed
to be removed from their tombs after the final
thousand day period, archeologists have unearthed
some of these self-mummified monks very recently,
implying that, for whatever reason, this removal
did not always happen, perhaps because the
body was not seen to have been preserved well
enough, so was simply left where
it was.